in this video you're going to learn
about how to work with Transformations
identifying whether it's a vertical
stretch or a vertical shrink or a
reflection or you know any different
type of transformation we're also going
to talk about the order of
Transformations as well as how to get a
good accurate graph of your function so
let's dive in we're going to start off
with some easy examples and then kind of
build and get more challenging we'll do
a lot of different problems see if you
can follow along see if you can try some
of these on your own if you want as you
get the hang of it so for the first
introductory example we're going to look
at the absolute value function see this
f of x equals absolute value of x this
is what's called our parent function
kind of like our core function before we
do all our Transformations so let's make
a table if we plug in some negative
values zero and a couple positive values
remember when you put this number in
it's always going to end up making it a
positive in the end so the absolute
value of negative 2 is just going to be
positive 2 the absolute value of
negative 1 is 1. absolute value of zero
is zero one and two so if we plot these
points here you can see this is going to
be negative 2 2
negative 1 1 0 0 1 1 2 2 Etc and what
this graph looks like it's a real sharp
a corner here like a v-shaped graph but
now let's go ahead and take a look at
some different uh Transformations here
and we're going to be using this
function notation a little bit uh later
in the video we're going to be talking
about how to work with the
Transformations using this but for uh
just starting off here now what we want
to do is we want to ask ourselves
is the number group with the x or not
group of the X this is the way I like to
think about it if it's grouped with the
X it's going to affect the x-axis
Direction the horizontal Direction but
it's going to have the opposite effect
what I mean by that is see like here how
we have f of x minus H if it was x minus
2 it actually would move the graph
positive 2 to the right if it was plus 2
it actually have the opposite effect it
would move it two to the left
but if it's not grouped with the X
meaning it's not in the absolute value
bars or Not underneath the square root
or not in in the parentheses if it's not
group of the X and it's going to affect
the Y values and it's going to have what
we call the same effect and so we're
going to talk about this so in this
first example see how the two is not
grouped with the X this is going to be
affecting the Y values it's going to be
multiplying all the Y values by 2 we
could multiply all these y values in our
table by 2 but essentially what's going
to happen if this is our original graph
this is actually going to be a vertical
stretch
by a factor of two so it's like you're
pulling on the graph in this y direction
the vertical Direction which is going to
make the graph narrower it's going up
you know faster and again that's going
to be this one here in function notation
see how that a value is in front of the
f of x it's multiplied when it's
multiplied or divide is going to be a
stretch or a shrink when you're adding
and subtracting that's going to be a
shift like you're picking it up and
you're moving it so let's go to the next
one g of X is equal to the absolute
value of x plus 1. now notice it's
grouped with the X so it's going to
affect the X Direction the horizontal
Direction it's an addition so adding
subtracting we're thinking of Shifting
right picking it up and shifting but
remember when it's grouped with the X it
has the opposite effect so the plus one
is actually going to move it to the left
one so now your graph is going to look
something like this where it's been
shifted one unit to the left now if
you're working with the table you can
just subtract 1 from all these X values
and then that would be your new point
would want to graph and we're going to
do more problems as we go through this
lesson this is just kind of an
introduction here now for letter C what
do you think is happening on this one g
of X is equal to the absolute value of x
minus 3. just like this one it's grouped
with the X so it's going to affect the X
Direction the X variable has the
opposite effect when it's grouped with
the X the minus 3 is going to shift
everything right 3.
and so now our grass is going to look
something like this if you want to be a
little bit more accurate with your table
you can just add three to all your x
coordinates plot those new points that
would be your graph for letter D we've
got G of x equals the absolute value of
x plus 2. now notice that this 2 is not
grouped with the X it's not in the
absolute value there that means when
it's not grouped with the X it's going
to affect the Y values okay up and down
we're adding that's going to be a shift
and when it's not grouped to the X it
has the same effect so the plus two
means we're going to shift this up to
and it's going to have the same shape
it's just shifted up too now with the
table what you can do is just add 2 to
all the Y coordinates and then plot
those new coordinates out of your graph
for letter e notice we have a negative
on the outside it's not grouped with the
X when it's not grouped with the X it
affects the Y values right so it's going
to make all the Y values the opposite or
multiply by negative 1. so what that's
going to do is you multiply all these y
values by negative one that's going to
reflect it over the x-axis making it
open down like that
whereas with letter f you see how the
negative is grouped with the X okay see
it's inside those absolute value bars
that's going to affect the x coordinates
or the X values and it's going to make
all the X values the opposite so if
they're positive they become negative if
they're Negative they become positive so
this is actually a reflection over the
y-axis because all the X's are opposite
now when you take this graph and you
reflect it over the y-axis here it's
just going to match to itself so you're
not really going to notice that the
graphs uh
change in any way when you graph it but
as far as describing the transformation
you'd say oh yes this is a reflection
over the y-axis and then our last
introductory example here we have this 1
4 grouped with the X now remember when
it's group of the X
it's affecting the X values this
horizontal Direction notice it's
multiplied remember adding and
subtracting is Shifting multiplying or
dividing is like stretching or shrinking
but the important thing to remember
group with the X has the opposite effect
right so the one-fourth is actually
going to multiply the X's by
the reciprocal four over one so this is
actually going to be a horizontal
stretch by a factor of 4. so imagine
taking this graph and pulling on it in
this horizontal direction that would
make it wider
like so now if you want to be more
accurate we're going to be more accurate
some of the next problems that we're
going to be doing I would just multiply
all these X values here by 4 the Y
values would stay the same those would
be our new coordinates and we can plot
those and be real precise and get a nice
graph so let's take a look at some other
parent functions that you're going to be
encountering let's talk about how to
graph them let's go to the next example
okay for example number two now let's
look at this square root function let's
plug in some easy numbers numbers that
are easy to take the square root of like
0 1 4 and 9. so the square root of zero
is zero square root of one is one square
root of 4 is 2 and square root of 9 is
3. if we plot these points we get 0 0 1
1 4 2 9 3 kind of goes off my graph a
little bit here but you can see this
graph is just going to the right it
almost looks like a like half a parabola
on its side like this so it's gradually
going up and it just goes to the right
okay like that now what we want to graph
now is this one here G of x equals one
half times the square root of x minus
one plus two so when I think about the
order of Transformations the way I like
to do it is I like to think about
working from the inside out okay so what
I mean by that is you know what are we
doing first are we doing the one first
the two first the one half what are we
doing so starting from the inside out I
would say we're going to do the one
first then this one half and then and
this true last so just a hint you're
going to want to do the vertical shift
up or down last okay some of the other
Transformations you can interchange and
it's not going to affect the end result
of your graph like for example I could
do this one half and then the one or
this one then the half but in general I
kind of like to start from the inside
and work my way out making sure I do
that vertical shift last
we're going to do some more challenging
problems and we'll talk about it but
starting on the inside here what do you
think this minus 1 does to the graph
well I can see it's grouped with the X
so that tells me it's going to be
affecting the X variable the horizontal
component of the graph
it's subtracted remember adding and
subtracting is going to be a shift like
you're picking it up and you're like
shifting it left or right but remember
when it's group of the X it has the
opposite effect right so that means the
minus 1 is actually going to shift this
graph right one
now if we're looking at this from a
perspective of the table
shifting right one means I'm going to
add 1 to the x coordinate so this is
going to be 1 1 plus 1 is 2 4 plus 1 is
5 and 9 plus 1 is 10. so I'm going to
cross out those old X values these are
our new ones
and then we're going to say the next
thing which is the one-half now the
one-half is a group of the X
no you can see it's not underneath the
square root that means when it's not
grouped with the X which variable does
it affect
the Y values right if it's grouped with
the x is affecting the X values if it's
not group of the x that affects the Y
values has the same effect what does
that mean the same effect well see how
the one-half is less than one it's
between zero and one we say that this is
a vertical shrink by a factor of
one-half so that means we're going to
multiply all the Y values by one half so
that means this is going to be zero
times a half which is zero one times a
half which is a half two times a half is
one and three times a half is 1.5 or 3
halves it crosses out the old ones but
as far as the grass concerned it's like
we're squeezing it towards the x-axis
because that's a vertical shrink by a
factor of a half now lastly remember we
said we always want to do that vertical
shift up and down last notice the two
it's not grouped with the X so remember
when it's not group of the X it affects
the Y values has the same effect meaning
plus two we're going to go up two okay
so and notice when you're adding that's
going to be a shift okay so adding or
subtracting is a shift multiply anger
dividing is like a stretch or a shrink
and so here we're going to be adding 2
to all the Y values because it's
shifting up two so that's going to be 2
2.53
3.5 Let's cross out those old y values
now we have everything we need to graph
our graph one comma two
is where we're starting
2 comma 2.5
right about here
5 comma 3 so let's see one two three
four five
3 is right about here
and 10 3.5 kind of goes off the graph a
little bit basically you can see
our graph now it's you can see it's a
little bit squished that was what the
one half did and the one you can see
shifted it right one the two shifted it
up two and that's our graph so great job
let's go look at another example
okay for example number three now we're
working with this function f of x equals
x squared this is called our quadratic
function and let's make a table like
we've been doing plot some easy numbers
so negative 2 squared is negative 2
times negative 2 or positive four
negative 1 squared is one zero squared
is zero one squared is one two squared
is four three squared is nine Etc now if
we plot these points you're probably
already familiar with this graph but
this is going to look like
parabola
which is basically a U-shaped graph
and
you can see kind of what that's doing
it's going up kind of like steeper and
steeper so this is our parent function
now we want to graph this one g of x
equals negative the quantity 2x squared
plus one and we want to identify the
order of Transformations meaning what do
we do first and second and third Etc so
what I like to do is I like to work from
the inside out I look at where that
variable X is the X represents like our
input and we say well what's happening
to that input well it looks like we're
multiplying the X values by two but
remember we say as a group with the X
yeah this 2 is grouped with the X so
that means it is going to be affecting
the the X Direction the X variable the
horizontal component but one is group of
the X it has the
opposite effects we're actually dividing
the X's by two or you could say dividing
by 2 is like multiplying by the
reciprocal one-half so I would say that
the first step is that this is a
horizontal shrink
by a factor of one-half now what that
does to the table here it's going to
multiply all these X values by one half
which is going to make this negative one
negative a half a zero times uh one half
is still zero one half and one Let's
cross out those old X values
now the next thing kind of working from
the inside out would be this negative
here now what does this negative do well
you can see that it's not grouped with
the X remember when it's not grouped
with the X it affects the y values right
and so it's going to multiply all the Y
values by negative one now when you
multiply all the Y values by negative
one the positive y values become
negative if they have negative y values
they become positive so what that's
doing is it's reflecting it over the
x-axis in function notation that would
look like this where the functions
multiplied by negative one so we're
going to multiply all these y values by
negative one so this is going to become
negative negative 0 times negative 1 is
still zero negative negative okay now
lastly is the plus one and remember we
said we always want to do that vertical
shift last right so the plus one the way
I like to think about it is if you want
kind of like a decision tree and a lot
of students want to know what do I do a
b c d what do I do first second third
right
ask yourself is it group with the X you
might even want to write this down as a
group of the x or not group with the X
not group of the X right it's not in the
parentheses it's not with the X right so
that's going to affect the X values of
the Y values the Y values right when
it's not group of the x that affects the
Y values when it's grouped with the X
remember it has the opposite effect when
it's not group of the X it has the same
effect what I mean by that is see the
plus one intuitively you'd think oh yeah
plus one that means it's getting bigger
by 1 is Shifting up one right okay and
the other thing you want to remember is
multiplying and dividing is stretching
and shrinking
okay adding and subtracting is Shifting
okay so in this case plus one means it's
a shift has the same effect because it's
not group of the X it's affecting the Y
values we're going up one do you follow
that so if I add one to all of these
this is going to be negative 3 0 1 0 and
negative 3. cross out the old y values
let's go ahead and plot these now we've
got negative one negative three
negative one half zero
zero one
half zero
and one negative three
see a little bit over here about right
here so basically what's happening is
you can kind of see well the the two
basically shrunk it horizontally so
instead of being like this it's more
like this the negative is reflecting it
the plus one is Shifting it up one so
there's our graph and you got it let's
look at another example okay so for
example number four now we're working
with the cubic function f of x equals x
to the third power that's called our
cubic function let's again plot some
easy points so negative two negative 1 0
1 and 2 negative 2 cubed is negative
eight negative one cubed is negative one
zero cubed is zero one cubed is one and
two cubed is eight
and if we plot those points let's see
what we get here so negative two up
eight
negative one
uh cubed is negative oops I made a
mistake here negative two negative
eights down here my mistake negative 1
negative one zero zero one one and two
eight so basically your graph looks like
this
okay and it goes down and up forever and
ever gradually goes to the left and
right forever and ever domain and range
is all real numbers so this is your
parent function your basic core graph
but now what we want to do is we want to
look at what happens here for this G of
X function 2 times the quantity x minus
1 cubed plus three so just take a moment
now what do you think is the first thing
we should do what's the First
Transformation
well
I like to work from the inside out so
the x minus 1 I would say let's do this
part first now in this problem it won't
really matter in our final result if
we'd use do this 2 first and then this
one but you want to make sure you do
this three here at the very end but I
again like to work from the inside out
so this x minus 1
let's go through the different steps so
we say to ourselves is it group with the
x or not grouped with the X
well it's in the parentheses so that
means it's grouped with the X which
means it's going to affect the X values
or the horizontal Direction but remember
when it's grouped with the X does it
have the same effect or the opposite
effect
opposite effects so the minus 1 is
actually going to go positive one okay
so it's going to go to the right one and
remember if you're adding or subtracting
we say it's a shift if it's multiplying
or dividing it's going to be like a
stretch or a shrink in this case you can
see we're adding or subtracting so it's
a shift so it's going to go right one
which means that we're going to add 1 to
all these X values right so negative 1 0
1 2 and 3. Let's cross out the old X
values
now let's work from the again inside out
the two is a little bit further away
here the two let's go through the steps
is a group with the x or not group with
the X well it's not in the parentheses
so I would say it's not grouped with the
X which means when it's not grouped with
the X it affects which one the x or the
Y the Y values right
and when it's not grouped with a Y it
has the same effect when it's not group
of the X has the same effect right it's
affecting the Y's and one other thing
we're multiplying see how it's right
next to this it's multiplying so when we
multiply or divide we're thinking
stretch or Shrink so putting all that
together this is going to be multiplying
the Y values by two that's a vertical
stretch by a factor of two in our table
we're going to multiply all these y
values by 2.
so let's do that and cross out the old y
values lastly last step the plus three
is a group of the x or not group of the
X well it's not in the parentheses so
I'd say it's not group of the X does it
affect the x or the Y values well if
it's not group of the axis affecting the
Y values okay which means it has the
same effect or the opposite effect well
if it's the Y's it has the same effect
if it's acting on the X's remember so it
has the opposite effect so this is going
to have the same effect adding or
subtracting is a shift so this is going
to be shifting
positive 3 Up 3 which means that we're
going to be adding 3 to our y values
because the Y controls the vertical
Direction so that means this is going to
be negative 13 1 3 5 19. Let's cross out
those old y values now we have our
coordinates here that we can plot right
so negative 1 negative 13 might be a
little bit off my graph here let's start
with 0 1. so 0 1 would be right about
here
uh 1 3 is going to be right about here
2 5 is going to be right about here
319 is going to be where one two three
up way up here so you can see this graph
is basically going like
this
and you've got a good sketch of your
graph so let's take a look at another
example okay let's look at example
number five here which is f of x equals
the cube root of x the last problem we
were doing was X cubed this is the cube
root of x so what number times itself 3
times is negative 8 that's going to be
negative 2 the cube root of negative 1
is negative 1. cube root of zero is zero
cube root of one is one and cube root of
8 is 2. if we plot this graph let's see
we've got left eight
Down 2 which is right about here left
one down one zero zero one one eight two
now sometimes students say well do we
have to memorize these
coordinates or these points well you
know you don't have to you can always go
ahead and recreate the table but what
you'll find after a while is that you
know you'll end up memorizing them and
it's it's good to kind of know some of
the basic ones so you don't have to kind
of recreate the wheel you know each time
you can basically just you know know
your key points and you have a starting
place but again you can always just make
a table and start there now we're going
to look at this function G of x equals
the cube root of 3x minus 3 and this is
a little bit more challenging of a
problem and that's where we're going to
start diving into this function notation
a little bit so I want to kind of show
you something here first let's imagine
if we had a little different function
say if our function was like this say if
it was
h of x equals
let's say the cube root of x minus three
okay so if we look at this function
right here there's only really one
transformation right you say well this
minus three what is that doing to the
graph well remember it's group with the
X so it's affecting the X values has the
opposite effect which means that it's
going to be going not minus 3 but
positive 3 and of course adding and
subtracting we know is a shift right
multiplying dividing is a stretch so
this is going to be going right three
shifting right three
but then let's say for example if we
have now this function notation G of X
is equal to
uh did I say yeah g of X is equal to H
of 3x now the wave functions work is
that whatever's in the parentheses right
here it goes in for X on the right right
so that means what I'm doing is I'm
going to take this 3x here I'm going to
put it in for X so if I do that this is
going to look like this the cube root of
3x minus 3 which is what we're working
with right here right
but what happened first
was it the
shifting right 3 or this 3 here like
what did what does this 3 do well we
know see this notation h of 3x this is
this function notation right here notice
the a is grouped with the X which means
it affects the X values has the opposite
effect which means we're not really
multiplying the X's by 3 we're
multiplying by the reciprocal one-third
which is going to be a horizontal shrink
okay dividing the X's by three or
multiplying by 1 3 it's the same thing
but what happened first
we actually went right three and then we
did a horizontal shrink by a factor of
one-third now this is where
we need to kind of talk a little bit
because you know how I said I work from
the inside out well the inside to me and
this problem is like what's underneath
this cube root like if I had a plus
seven over here that would come at the
very end or if I had maybe a two in
front I like to work from the inside
here so but when there's more than one
operation okay group with the X like
that
you want to think about how to build up
that function kind of like you know
those Russian dials where there's like a
a doll inside of a dial inside of a dial
so you kind of have to say well what's
my outer function and what's my inner
function right in this case the outer
function was was this right here this x
minus 3 and then what do we do we
replace this x with this 3x that's kind
of the inner Russian dial the inner one
the one on the inside that came after
that came second right
so here what we're going to do is we
said we're shifting right three which
means I'm going to add 3 to the X values
so that's going to be negative 5 2 3
4 11 right so let's cross out those old
X values then we said that we're doing a
horizontal shrink by a factor of
one-third which is going to multiply all
these X values by one-third so now we
have negative five thirds
two-thirds one four thirds eleven thirds
Let's cross out those old X values now
let's see if we can graph this so
negative Five Thirds that's like
negative one and two-thirds
negative two which is right about here
uh two-thirds negative one is right
about
here one zero is right here
four thirds which is like one and
one-third
up one right here and eleven thirds
which is three and two-thirds one two
three almost to four three up two is
going to be right about here
so there's our graph
something like that
and you got it so this one was a little
bit more challenging because we had more
than one thing going on here so one
thing from that uh rust uh nested
Russian dial scenario let's look at
another example okay now depending on
your class and what you're learning and
what level you're at you might only need
to know what we talked about in examples
one through four and example five we got
a little bit more challenging we're
gonna do some other types of problems as
we go through so you might want to stick
with me to learn a little bit some more
techniques that you'll be using in the
future or your class might actually be
involved with this right now if you're
taking like a pre-calculus class or
college algebra type class
but let's look at number six now we've
already talked about the absolute value
graph we know what our table looks like
we know we have that v-shaped graph but
we want to graph this one g of x equals
the absolute value of 2 times the
quantity X plus 2 inside of that
absolute value
now depending on what level you're at
you know in your your learning of
Transformations your teacher might say
why don't you just rewrite this like why
don't you just say G of X is equal to
the absolute value of 2 times X plus 2
and then the absolute value of 2 is just
2 and then see we kind of rewrote and
Rewritten it in a little bit simpler
form so now you can kind of think about
it from this perspective and that might
be a lot easier
but
your teacher might want you to describe
the order of Transformations as the
function as given right here so what I
would ask and this problem is
what do you think you would do first and
what do you think you would do second
well another way to look at it is like
what's the innermost function what's the
outermost function and when you're
building up this function here what you
might want to think about is okay if I
had another function let's just call
this instead of G of X let's call this h
of X so we'll say h of X is equal to
um
let's just say it's 2X and then we'll
say G of X is equal to
um
h of X Plus 2. now remember whatever's
in the parentheses it's going to go in
for X on the right so what that means is
what we're going to be replacing x with
this quantity X plus 2 which is going to
give us this function that we have
right here right so what happened first
well it looks like we're actually doing
the multiplication here
first okay and then we're doing this X
plus 2 second this addition second so
the two notice it's grouped with the X
it's going to affect the X values but
when it's group of the X it has the
opposite effect which means we're
actually going to be multiplying the X's
by a half that's a horizontal shrink I'm
going to multiply all my X values in
this table by a half
cross out the old ones and then the X
plus 2 is group of the X it's affecting
the X values has the opposite effect
it's going to be actually going
-2 we're going to be shifting to the
left two okay and so that means we're
going to be subtracting 2 from all our X
values so that's going to make this
negative 3 negative 2.5 negative 2
negative 1.5 and negative 1. cross out
those old X values so if we plot these
points now negative 3 4 is going to put
us right about here
negative two and a half
1 is going to put us right about here
and
oh I'm okay that's good and then
negative 2 0 is going to put us right
here at negative one and a half one is
going to put us right here and negative
1 4 is going to put us right about here
so our graph looks still that absolute
value that v-shaped graph but look what
happened we did a vertical I'm sorry
horizontal shrink by one half okay and
then we pick that graph up and we
shifted it left two
so that's that's the idea now again you
can rewrite it or you can think about
how do I build up that function kind of
like if you're doing one step at a time
how would I create this function think
about the nested dials what's the the
outermost function and then what's the
innermost function like we're replacing
this x with X plus two so they actually
came
second right let's take a look at
another example okay before we do
example number seven if you're enjoying
my videos and you like the way that I
explain things and you want to go deeper
with me into learning more about Algebra
1 Algebra 2 college algebra check out my
video courses for sale in the
description below and if you just want
to support the videos that I'm putting
up here on my Mario's masterton YouTube
channel consider supporting me as a
channel member so you can join the
channel as a channel member and for a
few dollars a month you can support the
videos I'm putting up here and I really
appreciate it I see the members coming
through and I can see who's you know
been a member for so many months et
cetera et cetera and I really get a kick
out of that and I really appreciate that
so I definitely appreciate that let's
see if we can
um do number seven now if you want to
try this problem on your own go ahead
and pause the video notice we've got a
negative square root of negative X plus
two plus one how would you do that one
well if I was going to do this problem I
would do like I normally do I'd start
from the inside out but I would think
about those nested dolls again I would
say to myself if I was building up this
function I might say like h of x equals
the square root of x plus 2 and then I'm
replacing this x let's just say G of X
with h of negative X and remember
whatever's in the parenthesis goes in
for X so now what we have is negative X
plus two so what came first what came
second looks like the plus 2 came first
right so we're actually shifting left
two which means we're going to subtract
2 from the X values so negative 2
negative 1 2 and 7 cross out the old
ones then we're replacing this x with
negative X
which is this function notation right
here when it's group of the X remember
it affects the X values it makes all the
X values the opposite which is going to
reflect it over the y-axis when you
reflect over the y-axis all these X
values are the opposite signs so this is
going to become positive positive
negative negative
this negative on the outside that's this
one right here this is making all the Y
values the opposite which is going to
reflect it over the x-axis now all the Y
values the opposite I'm going to
multiply by negative 1 so that's going
to be 0 negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
and then lastly the plus one that's not
grouped with the X that's going to
affect the Y values it has the same
effect which means we're going to shift
in the y direction up one remember
adding is going to be a
shift right meaning we're picking it up
and shifting it up one which means we're
going to add 1 to all these y values so
1 0 negative 1 negative 2 cross off
those old y values okay so that's the
order of Transformations now could we
have done this in another order sure we
could have done the reflection over the
x-axis first
and then shifted left two and then
reflected over the y-axis and then
shifted up one that's another
possibility
you just want to make sure that this
comes last here the order was you know
is important okay so let's go ahead and
plot these so we've got two comma 1
which is going to be right about here 1
0 which is right here
uh negative 2 negative 1 is right there
and negative seven negative two let's
see so three four five six seven
negative two
so you can see this graph is bending
kind of like that okay so domain would
be well from negative Infinity to 2 or
you can say x is less than or equal to
negative two the range would be Y is
less than or equal to one or you could
say negative Infinity to one if you're
using the interval notation
so great job if you're able to get that
one let's take a look at a few more
examples
I know these Transformations can be
really challenging for a lot of students
if you have a question put it in the
comments below and if you're catching on
to this see if you can help some of
those commenters out you know kind of
walking through why these
Transformations work the way that they
do and try to see if you can answer
those questions you learn something
through explaining uh you kind of learn
it at a deeper level but yeah don't be
afraid to comment below if you have a
question let's look at this one here now
we've got G of x equals the quantity one
half x minus four squared minus two
see if you can label the order of
Transformations what you would do first
second third fourth fifth etcetera and
see if you can get a good sketch of your
graph here
now if I was going to do this problem
we've already talked about the quadratic
table in the basic graph that basic
parent function so what I would do is
I'd say well how could I if I was
building up this function how could I
build it up
now some teachers okay and some people
explain this like when you have more
than one quantity group with the X like
this what they'll say is that it has
like the
opposite of the PEMDAS you know you know
how you do parentheses exponents
multiplication division addition
subtraction so what they would say is
they'd say well we've got multiplication
here and subtraction here normally you
do multiplication first and subtraction
second right but when you're doing the
order of Transformations and it's
grouped with the X like that you would
actually do the opposite direction of
the order of uh operations you would say
I'm going to do this minus 4 first and
then the multiplication by one half
second it's like counterintuitive I find
that to be a little bit confusing
um it's a good little hack or a quick
way of doing it but I like to kind of
think of how would I create this
function I might start off by saying h
of x equals x minus 4
squared right
and then what I'm doing is I'm replacing
this x let's just call this G of X now
with um
eight h of one half
X
okay I didn't need this parenthesis here
now what happens is whatever is in
parentheses here goes in for X what I'm
going to do is I'm going to replace x
with one half X
like that right so what happened first
well you can see this is kind of like
our starting function the minus 4 it's
group of the X that's going to shift it
right four
so let's add 4 to all the X's that's
going to be 2 3 4 5 and 6. and then you
can see we replace that x with the one
half X
okay so it's grouped with the X it's
multiply which is going to be a stretch
or a shrink when it's grouped with the X
it has the opposite effect or reciprocal
effect in this case you're going to be
multiplying the X's by 2 which is a
horizontal stretch by a factor of 2
which means I'm going to multiply all
these X values by 2.
cross out the old ones and then lastly
remember we always want to do that
vertical shift
up or down last the minus two it's not
group of the X so we know it's affecting
the Y values has the same effect minus 2
is going down two so we're going to
subtract 2 from all the Y values
Christmas
cross out the old ones and now we can
plot these points so let's go ahead and
do that so 4 2 would be right about here
6 negative 1 would be right about here 8
negative 2 would be right about here
10 negative 1 would be let's see 9 10
about here and twelve two
would be right about here
okay so this is
something like that right
so you can see that the graph is wider
right that's what this did but first we
shifted it right four okay which would
be right here but then when we stretched
it see that vertex now see if when we
first was at right four like this when
we stretched it the X's by two the
horizontal stretch this point went over
here to eight then we shifted it down
two and that's how we're getting that
that new graph so let's take a look at
another example I like that quote by
Madame Curie I believe it is you said
that nothing in life is to be feared
only to be understood so I know these
can be really challenging but I hope
you're catching on to this and if you're
stuck with this video so far great job
we've got a couple more examples let's
look at number nine we've got f of x
equals one over X this is called the
reciprocal function and some easy
numbers here to a plot would be like a
negative 2 negative one zero one two and
you're going to get these y values and
when you graph it it's going to look
some something like like this it's a
hyperbola it gets closer and closer to
the x-axis and the y-axis you've got
some asymptotes here right at the x-axis
and y axis that's your basic graph
but let's let's see if we can go through
the order of transformation so what are
the first second third Transformations
here and how would you graph it how
could you get a good sketch see if you
can do that one
keep in mind that there's more than one
order okay but uh where you can get the
same answer but there's definitely the
wrong way to do it as well so if I was
going to do it
I would think about building it up like
we were talking about using these
function notation here first so what I
might say is let's maybe look at a
function like this let's just say you
have y equals 4 over X okay so what did
I do to get from 1 over X to 4 over X
well it looks like I multiplied by four
right it's like it's basically like if I
have my function f of x equals 1 over X
and now let's say I have G of X is equal
to 4 times f of x
that's this one right here so see how
it's not grouped with the X it's
affecting the Y values that's a vertical
stretch remember when you multiply it's
a stretch or Shrink it has the same
effect when it's acting on the Y so it's
stretching or multiplying the Y's by a
factor of four so if I multiply all
these by 4 I get negative two a negative
4. this is undefined so that we won't
worry about that one one times four is
four and one half times four is two
now this negative here what's this
negative doing
well the negative you can see it's
taking this quantity here and it's
multiplying it by negative one so that's
going to be this one right here
it's not grouped with the X it's
affecting the Y values which all the Y
values are the opposite that's going to
reflect it over the x-axis so we're
going to multiply all the Y values by
negative one
okay so I'm just flipping the signs
and then now let's look at this X Plus 1
here so this X Plus 1 is going to shift
the graph left one and see it's grouped
with the X okay it's with the X
okay
and it's having the opposite effect so
shifting it left one which means I'm
going to subtract one from all the X
values here
cross out the old ones and then lastly
remember we want to do the vertical
shift up or down last so the minus 2
affects the Y values it has the same
effect as shifting down two so we're
going to subtract 2 from all the Y
values here so 0 2 negative
6 and negative 4. cross out the old one
so let's see if we can plot this now so
we have negative three zero put a point
there negative 2 2
okay and 0 negative six one two three
four five six and one negative four
and what's interesting here is you can't
divide by zero so at negative one you
would have a vertical asymptote this
minus two shifts everything down to so
this horizontal asymptote is being
shifted down to so you have a horizontal
asymptote at y equals negative two and
so your basic shape here of your graph
would look something like this
and you got it so let's try one last
example
okay we've got f of x equals the
greatest integer
function so the greatest integer
function what this does is it always
rounds down to the nearest integer okay
and it's oftentimes referred to as the
step function because when you graph it
it looks like stairs so here what we do
is we put 0 in 0 would round to zero
it's already at the integer value 0.5
would round to zero zero point nine nine
nine would round to zero but at one you
would stay at one
because you're already at that integer
value 1.5 would round to the left on the
number line to one 1.999 would round to
the left of the number line to one and
then two you're at the next integer two
so if we plot these points see Zero Zero
would be right here
0.50
0.9990 but as soon as you get to one
there's going to be an open circle here
and you're going to jump up to the next
step or stair okay 1.5 would be 1 1.99
is 1. as soon as you get to 2 here is an
open circle and you jump up to The Next
Step at two once you get a few of these
steps you can repeat it so you can see
it's open on the right and closed on the
left and it just keeps going in both
directions like that so that's your your
step function your greatest integer
function but what do you think this
here would do the 2x minus 1. what's the
order of Transformations how would you
get a good sketch of that graph try that
one well like I said at the very
beginning like I like to work from the
inside out so I would say hmm this 2 is
group of the x that means it's going to
affect the X Direction the horizontal
Direction
when it's group of the X it has like the
opposite effect what I mean by that is
if you know you're multiplying by two
you're actually going to divide X's by
two or multiply by one half either one
it's the same thing
and when you're multiplying dividing
that's a stretch or a shrink so this is
actually going to be a horizontal shrink
by a factor of one-half
and then the minus 1 is going to shift
it down one so horizontal shrink by a
factor of a half means I'm going to
multiply all these numbers by
um a half so this is going to be zero
this is going to be 0.25 this is going
to be like point
four nine nine this is going to be a
half this is going to be 0.75 this is
going to be like point
999 roughly and this is going to be one
okay now the minus 1 is going to shift
everything down one which means I'm
going to subtract 1.
from all of these
y values okay so now if we plot these
let's see what this looks like so we
have at 0 we're at negative 1.
at 0.25 we're at negative 1 at 0.499
we're at negative one at a half
we're at zero so what happens is that
right you go all the way up to a half
and then you jump up like that
okay and then you can see a 0.75 I'm at
0.99 I'm at zero and as soon as I get to
one
I jump up to one so that means it's
going to be open here I'm going to jump
up like that so what's happening now if
you can see this
is the two
divided the X values by two so that it
made all these stairs like uh half is
long right so actually squeeze it
towards the y-axis they're half as long
and then the minus one we shifted it
down one so basically every half on the
axis jumping up as opposed to every one
integer it's jumping up
so and it continues so great job I hope
this made Transformations a lot easier
for you to understand if you want to get
more practice or you want to see another
video I did about these transformations
follow me over to that video right there
and we'll get some more practice I'll
see you in that video